ebbene sì alcuni adolescenti fanno sesso
c'è chi inizia prima c'è chi inizia dopo
c'è chi inizia con maggiore serenità o
chi con più ansia difficoltà qualche
preoccupazione
ragionando su quale sia l'età giusta su
come iniziare questo tipo di esperienza
in maniera sana serena o chi si butta e
quindi ebbene sì alcuni adolescenti ea
volte anche dei pre adolescenti fanno
sesso hanno contatti sessuali
questo può fare strano soprattutto a noi
adulti se siamo i loro genitori oi loro
insegnanti può farci paura a volte se
siamo i classici adulti di riferimento
quindi quelle persone che in qualche
modo devono pensare a queste dolescente
come persone non solo in grado di
intendere e di volere ma anche in grado
di volere godere desiderare
ecco gli adolescenti fanno sesso e non è
qualcosa di facile da pensare anche da
un punto di vista istituzionale in
italia in italia ad oggi non esiste un
educazione della sessualità che sia
capillare
integrata
se ne parla sempre di più è un tema in
grande
diciamo su cui c'è grandissima
attenzione se ne parla sempre di più sui
social e ragazzi e ragazze diciamo che
trovano delle risposte alle loro domande
ripeto sempre di più all'interno di
contesti informali quindi chiacchierando
tra pari chiacchierando con gli adulti
chiacchierando nei bagni delle scuole
luogo principe dell'educazione sessuale
degli adolescenti di oggi anche
probabilmente del passato però
all'interno dei contesti più formali
istituzionali oggi in italia vige è una
presa in carico
diciamo così a macchia di leopardo o per
lo più se mi permettete un diffuso
silenzio io ho lavorato nel contesto
olandese ad esempio è spesso l'italia
viene messo in paragone con altri paesi
europei e si dice che sì su questi temi
siamo un po indietro e la cultura
italiana insomma è in parte vero in
italia l'educazione alla sessualità oggi
non esiste come in qualche modo dovrebbe
però tuttavia le domande dei ragazzi e
delle ragazze ci sono sono lì sono
domande molto complesse molto articolate
a volte buffe strampalate sorprendenti a
volte anche un po preoccupanti o
scioccanti ecco io sono una di quelle
persone
che a quelle domande ha il piacere di
rispondere è davvero un privilegio a
volte ho proprio questa sensazione
quando mi trovo in una classe con
ragazzi e ragazze ad ascoltare i loro
dubbi appunto le loro domande loro
quesiti a raccogliere le loro opinioni
come voi sapete ragazzi e ragazze sono
spesso timidi intimiditi o quantomeno in
difficoltà a parlare di questi temi a
volte invece sono presuntuosi
conservatori prepotenti che puzzolenti
insomma lo sappiamo abbastanza che
spesso lo sono ecco io sono una persona
che si occupa di educazione alla
sessualità e che passa gran parte del
suo tempo professionale finché dura
perché insomma il futuro professionale
purtroppo non è garantito
passa il suo tempo a raccogliere questo
tipo di dubbi e di complessità
esperienziale mi occupo da una decina
d'anni di educazione della sessualità
collaborando con diverse istituzioni
locali e nazionali e lavoro con ragazzi
e ragazze dai 13 14 anni in su e con
appunto i cosiddetti adulti di
riferimento quindi famiglie educatori
educatrici insegnanti personale dei
servizi socio sanitari quindi ostetriche
e ginecologi e psicologi e psicologi e
devo dire che con gli adulti mi diverto
molto ma come potete immaginare con i
ragazzi che c'è la parte più bella di
questo lavoro
ecco quindi
che cosa chiedono i ragazzi e le ragazze
quali sono le loro domande domande vi
ripeto a volte fatti a gran voce
cercando un po di provocare oppure fatte
sommessamente sottovoce magari girati di
spalle perché si prova un po di
imbarazzo a stare con la propria classe
a parlare appunto di sessualità o di
affettività oppure domande affidati a
quei bigliettini anonimi
spiaccicati che insomma io stesso devo
aprire
rivelando poi un tesoro fatto di
emozioni dubbi preoccupazioni
ecco sono domande che spaziano
tantissimo riguardano spesso i
cambiamenti del corpo che durante la
pubertà si fa elettrico si fa
ingestibile si fa irrefrenabile nei suoi
desideri
tra altezza che non crescono mai
abbastanza
cosce troppo grosse pancia ed a
mascherare muscoli da coltivare
eni da misurare
ricordo una volta un ragazzo si chiedeva
se nel pene ci fosse o meno un osso
chissà
sono stesso domande che riguardano l'età
giusta per fare sesso per avvicinarsi
alla sessualità domande che spesso
riguardano i rapporti con la famiglia il
conflitto la scoperta del proprio
orientamento sessuale della propria
identità di genere e devo dire ancora
costantemente la paura spesso di fare
coming out non tanto con i pari lo
stesso con famiglie che vengono definite
omofobe o quantomeno in difficoltà
domande che riguardano ovviamente la
contraccezione la prevenzione delle
infezioni sessualmente trasmissibili
ne ricordo una recente ma il dentista se
ne può accorgere se ho già fatto sesso
orale
domande che spaziano davvero tantissimo
ce ne sono di buffe ce ne sono anche di
molto provocatorie di molto forti
domande che davvero
restituiscono quanto la pubertà
sconvolga la vita di un adolescente se
si fa sesso essere vegetariani o vegani
lo si fa meglio e tantissime domande
tantissime sull'amore come si forma come
lo si riconosce come se fosse un
elefante nella stanza su cui puntare il
dito che si può imparare a vedere a
riconoscere ecco io credo che la mia
idea di upgrade in qualche modo oggi nel
contesto italiano è quella di concepire
la sessualità anche degli adolescenti
come qualcosa di complesso di bello di
importante e che quindi come società
come comunità educante possiamo
cominciare a pensarla ea farla questa
educazione della sessualità in modo
integrato che cosa vuol dire vuol dire
non solo concependola e gestendo la come
se fosse una questione sanitaria
devo contenere i rischi
devo limitare i danni gravidanza
indesiderata in adolescenza prevenzione
della violenza
prevenzione della diffusione delle
infezioni sessualmente trasmissibili
c'è qualcosa che manca c'è qualcosa che
manca
io credo che oggi l'upgrade educativo
politico sociale culturale che riguarda
questo aspetto sia quello di pensare
appunto all'educazione della sessualità
e all'affettività in modo integrato con
rienzi come suggerisce lo ms l'unesco
perché in ballo c'è qualcosa di molto
importante
in ballo c'è la prevenzione della
violenza omofoba dell'omonegatività
della violenza di genere
che cosa vuol dire in concreto che cosa
c'è in ballo
in ballo c'è il prevenire o in ragionare
quantomeno su quanto modelli e
stereotipi di genere sessisti incidano
si inscrivono nei corpi nell'identità e
nelle esperienze e rosico relazionali
dei più giovani
spoiler non solo dei più giovani anche
delle nostre come adulti
ricordo per esempio la ragazza che dice
beh bello questo progetto però se le
prove si accorgono che il sesso mi
interessa cioè cosa penseranno di me
oppure beh dai si è vestita così oppure
si mette così sui social è un po se l'è
cercata se poi l'anno molestata
oppure ragazzi che spesso in maniera
molto innocente anche ingenuo passatemi
il termine è un vero maschio cioè
dovrebbe essere eterosessuale oppure la
ragazza che mi insegue nei famosi bagni
della scuola chiedendomi beh io questi
rapporti con il mio ragazzo non sono
troppo convinta se mi piacciano non mi
piacciono però vabbè dai lasciamo stare
il mio piacere quello non conta
l'importante tutto sommato che ti
piaccia a lui oppure ragazzine che
ricordo sempre con tantissima simpatia
che durante un piccolo incontri in cui
eravamo solo tra ragazze quindi un
ambiente molto protetto continuavano a
parlare della parola con la v
la parola con la v poi ridendo
ridacchiando hanno cominciato a parlare
di patti e cioè chi è chiesta patti
cos'è la parola con la v
cercando di stimolare poi la discussione
tra una risata e un silenzio e poi
un'ammissione insomma del proprio della
propria difficoltà le ragazze parlavano
della vagina della vulva non parlavano
di tuberi o di patate chiamandola patti
ecco se in qualche modo parlare di
sessualità di corpi è ancora così
difficile così complesso se le immagini
anatomiche per esempio dei manuali di
scienze non contengono spesso i genitali
esterni soprattutto femminili perché il
piacere non è il programma di scienze e
laddove invece ci sono vengono definiti
un po violenti forse un po troppo
perturbanti abbiamo un problema di
sessismo
abbiamo un problema rispetto al fatto
che alcuni modelli alcuni stereotipi
appunto sessisti di genere legati al
maschile al femminile ai confini entro i
quali essere nel modo giusto
maschi e femmine incidono sul modo
attraverso il quale parlare e vivere la
sessualità
ecco io credo che in questo senso una
sorta di secondo upgrade potrebbe essere
quello di concepire quanto sotto
l'educazione alla sessualità c'è
rispetto a queste questioni qui sono
temi bioetici sono questioni politiche
sono questioni sociali culturali di
profondissima e di grandissima
importanza e quindi il secondo grade
vorrebbe essere proprio quello di
concepire al centro dell'educazione
della sessualità non solo la prevenzione
ma anche la promozione di comportamenti
sicuri responsabili basati sul rispetto
sulla condivisione che mettono il centro
due concetti secondo me fondamentali
strettamente connessi quello di consenso
e quello di piacere poiché un educazione
alla sessualità che tralascia il tema
del piacere non può essere un educazione
alla sessualità che tematizza davvero il
tema del consenso di cui si parla sempre
di più fortunatamente
è così non riesco a parlare di di
piacere e quindi non riesco a
comprendere quanto c'è che possa essere
piacevole per me come faccio a
riconoscere quello che non mi piace
ecco consenso e piacere devono essere
due parti fondamentali da cui non si può
prescindere
è un'altra cosa importante
io credo sia quella di raccogliere
l'esperienza dei ragazzi e delle ragazze
il che vuol dire ascoltare la loro voce
e anche la loro difficoltà rispetto a
questi argomenti qui poiché parlare di
piacere di consenso in qualche modo
permette a tutte le persone di mettersi
in discussione adulti e giovani compresi
una domanda che spesso vi viene in mente
che ricordo mi turbò molto nella aprirla
fu quella differenza tra sesso e stupro
ecco spesso ci sono anche questo tipo di
domande voi vi rendete conto
e assolutamente fondamentale
implementare
capillarizzare accogliere il vissuto dei
ragazzi e delle ragazze anche nei loro
stereotipi nei loro frequentissimi
riferimenti ad esempio la pornografia
più mainstream a cui fanno riferimento
e che costituisce ad oggi come si tende
a dire la più diffusa educazione alla
sessualità
ecco io credo che accogliere la loro
voce sia assolutamente
fondamentale nel senso che accompagnare
i ragazzi e le ragazze ragionare anche
noi adulti su come si può essere
soggetti di desiderio
oltre che oggetti sia assolutamente
importante imprescindibile per
l'autodeterminazione di ciascuno adulto
adolescente che sia
ecco
una cosa cui penso spesso in questi
laboratori molto faticosi e che in
realtà è uno spazio di apprendimento
reciproco
quello è uno spazio di apprendimento
circolare dove non sono io l'adulto che
insegna ai ragazzi e alle ragazze ma
sono loro che in qualche modo insegnano
a me a ricordare soprattutto che il
sesso
non può essere sicuro è una
è una vertigine un brivido è un salto
nel vuoto nel vuoto dentro di noi e
nell'altro è sempre un viaggio un
viaggio senza ritorno un viaggio da cui
si torna sempre in qualche modo
sconvolti rinnovati e non può essere
sicuro e apprezzare questo accoglierlo e
condividerlo anche con i ragazzi e le
ragazze
personalmente credo che sia un
grandissimo piacere e sia in qualche
modo un dovere di una comunità educante
composta da adulti e non solo
mi torna spesso in mente infatti
l'etimologia della parola a educare ex
ducere tirare fuori e io spesso sento
che siano più i ragazzi e le ragazze a
tirare fuori da me dalle mie farfalle
nella pancia
quello che io sento più che tirare fuori
io qualcosa da da loro e sono in quei
momenti in cui l'area si sospende in cui
in quel silenzio in quegli sguardi in
quelle notte torturate in quello sguardo
no basso tra le amiche e complici o tra
la coppia che un po si sta piacendo che
c'è la bellezza dell'occasione
dell'educazione alla sessualità per come
la vedo io per come la propongo intesa
come upgrade
e alla luce di questo vorrei chiudere
valorizzando ancora l'importanza delle
domande che sono spazi di possibilità
chiedendo a voi quale sarebbe stata la
vostra domanda
affidata ad una classe ad un gruppo una
delle mie preferite più recenti quando
si parla di masturbazione tema
fondamentale dell'educazione più sex
positivo che si tende a fare e alzi la
mano chi non si è mai masturbato ecco i
ragazzi fanno anche queste provocazioni
la domanda che io vorrei fare a voi
promuovendo un idea di educazione alla
sessualità che possa essere sex positivo
quindi inclusiva plurale quale sarebbe
stata la vostra domanda è quale sarebbe
oggi la vostra la vostra risposta perché
io credo che davvero si possa in qualche
modo oggi parlare di educazione in
chiave positiva e propositiva
proattiva dove la verginità non è più
qualcosa che si perde ma corrisponde a
una sorta di debutto sessuale
relazionale dove le identità gli
orientamenti possono essere tutti
accolti e valorizzato e quando si fanno
degli esempi anche nel prevenire le
infezioni sessualmente trasmissibili si
possa e si debba far riferimento anche
ad esperienze affettive di tipo non
eterosessuale
laddove tutte le identità possano essere
non sono accolte tollerati ma
valorizzate comprese ecco io credo che
ricordarci ripensare a quella che poteva
essere la nostra domanda e pensare oggi
a quale potrebbe essere la nostra
risposta
mi fa tornare in mente un ultimo quesito
in che modo
l'adolescenza in realtà all'adolescenza
perché c'era un tenerissimo errore
grammaticale influenza l'età adulta
ecco alla luce del quanto sappiamo qual
è la risposta a questa domanda vorrei
che ripensasse alla domanda e alla
risposta che vi dareste oggi ma che
soprattutto pensaste all'adolescente che
siete stato e che in parte spero in
qualche modo siate ancora per continuare
ad ascoltarlo e il suo essere
sgangherato ma anche per valorizzarlo
apprezzarlo e in qualche modo amarlo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]